so what's this guy going to talk about
i'm going to talk about architecture
that's what i've been doing for the last
25 years and
specifically i'm going to talk about
building the optimal architecture for
open banking
and touch on a lot of the same subjects
that jason was talking about as well
so what the heck is happening
to banks well banks are evolving they're
transforming very quickly
into technology companies you don't have
to look very hard to see this happening
it's happening across the board it's
happening in payments and mortgages and
in retail and in wealth
just about everywhere you look in
banking in finance you see
non-bank entities technology entities
nibbling away
at the bank's uh business so
what are banks to do well they have to
learn some new tricks the kind of tricks
that technology companies already know
they have to learn about things like
agile and devops and public cloud and of
course
everybody's favorite apis
ever heard of them anybody no so
apis the rise of the api
well as everyone knows apis are the
pipelines that power
open banking i don't want to patronize
the folks in the audience so i'm going
to do this super quick
uh what is open banking this is a source
of much debate let me give you what i
see
as a as an architect as the simplest
definition
and if you're in the same kind of
debates uh with incumbents that i am
they they like to split these hairs so i
find this to be a very useful structure
partner apis when you're hooking into
visa so you can issue a visa card
is not open banking those are partner
apis
so when you do a one-to-one agreement
with some other company and hook into
their api that we've been doing for 30
years plus
doesn't count not open banking no matter
what the incumbents tell you
open apis so you're starting to get
there this means
you have an api posted somewhere on some
publicly accessible site
that somebody can go sight unseen and
start to use and test in a sandbox and
sign up and use the production version
better but if it was written
using your proprietary data structures
using proprietary protocols stuff that
your
bank came up with you're kind of
hard-pressed to really call that
open banking open banking happens when
those apis become standardized
okay so open banking happens when an
ecosystem of players
who are all participating uh with each
other trying to offer financial services
are using a common set
of apis that to me is open banking
far left of the diagram that's that's
really what i would consider closed and
there's a bit of a continuum as banks
start to share more and more of their
data more and more of the capabilities
until you arrive
what we now know as open banking the
thing is even with that definition
depending on who you speak to open
banking means different things to
different people
so let's take a quick look at the global
landscape if you go to open banking
shows like i do
on vacation sometimes you'll see a chart
like this that talks about where all the
countries are
and and and how they're doing this one's
a little dated it's from eighty carney
uh from from about uh uh almost a year
ago now
um so there has been some movement like
i said don't ask about canada
that's why the question marks um but
what you see here is
is two important axes a market axis
and a regulatory axis and the way a t
carney discusses these is the the market
is a poll
where effectively you're being pulled
into open banking
by market forces by competition and a
regulatory push where there is some sort
of regulation that is compelling you to
move towards open banking
you can see that there are some regions
that are regulatory driven in some
regions that are market driven what's
interesting again as an architect you
end up in sort of the same place
i'm not going to talk about the politics
i said that i wouldn't
uh but from a technical standpoint you
still end up with a consistent set of
standards that everybody's going to
share you still end up with this notion
of a registry and you still end up with
some kind of a a
model for governing participants in the
ecosystem it doesn't matter
whether you're regulatory driven or
market driven open banking is open
banking it's trying to achieve the same
goals
so if i'm not going to talk about
this stuff the politics and i promised i
was going to talk about architecture
how do these two different approaches to
open banking influence
the architecture so
it's very interesting because no
open banking standard that i am aware of
anywhere in the world
talks about what to do
with your stack so all the standards
will talk about apis
they'll talk about these are the apis
you need to publish and and this is what
they should do and they should broadly
cover payments and they should cover
accounts and customer information and
and so on and they differ slightly and
they certainly differ in their data
representations
but none of them say anything about
microservices or cicd or public cloud
support
or even particular security protocols
and so on
so what that means is in regulatory
driven
environments you effectively have a
forced march to get the apis right
you have a deadline some regulators
yelling at you they've set out the broad
guidelines
and if you're in a large company you
have limited i.t resources you don't
have all the i
all the money in the world you're going
to have to figure out how to spend your
money and if a regulator is telling you
you have a deadline well you're going to
take those limited resources
and work on the front you're going to
get the apis right
you're going to get the api management
right a lot of folks here and at other
open banking shows we'll talk about
things like api management
so that's what the banks in regulated
regions did they
they got really good at the api stuff
the thing is
they didn't have enough resources left
to work on the bottom part of the stack
in all the regions where there isn't a
regulatory driver
and you essentially have financial
services companies going
i definitely have to compete with these
technology folks but i don't have a
regulatory mandate to get the apis right
what am i going to work on well the
answer in word is speed
right what regions like canada regions
like the us have been focused on
is getting as good as technology
companies at delivery at what is
commonly called cicd continuous
improvement continuous delivery
running an automated pipeline having an
architecture
that supports that automation and trying
to get your release frequency up to that
amazon google netflix uber kind of a
level
that's what banks like mine have been
working on is getting
faster so whereas in the regulatory
environment you've got a focus on really
developer experience
api management uh how's the portal can
developers come in and use it easily
in market driven environments we've been
focusing a lot on isolation of business
capabilities which gets into things like
domain driven design
and vertical teams two pizza teams you
get into objects and models which gets
into things like event sourcing
and eventual consistency and dealing
with distributed data
and of course we have to deal with
modern environments such as
hybrid cloud portability across cloud
environments
uh how to integrate legacy ingress
egress points etc
so there's a ton of stuff that we've
been focusing on in the absence of
regulation the thing is
a complete open banking solution
requires both
these things you can't have just speed
without
proper api management and you can't have
proper api management without
the ci cd uh plumbing to back it up
so how does this uh how do you do that
right how do you start to develop an
architecture that sort of brings these
two worlds together
well that's where you get to this muddy
term api gateway
now when i started down the journey of
modernizing our integration environment
i i started to to read a lot of papers
that called me a dinosaur because i
still did soa and soap and xml
and started to look into okay what's
this cool new rest json way this is a
few years ago now
and you quickly run into this term api
gateway but
wow it seemed impossible to pin down
what exactly
people meant when they said api gateway
surely nginx was not the same as
mulesoft
they're radically different toolsets so
what the heck did people mean
and as you started to dissect the market
you start to realize what a lot of folks
meant
a couple years ago a lot has changed
since then
was what i like to call the magic black
box and that means
i'm going to give you a hub it's got all
sorts of connectors and adapters and
stuff
hook all your systems into my hub and
it's just going to auto magically fix
all your problems for you
i've been in this business for 25 years
i've seen this strategy come and go
by many different names before it was
called an api gateway it was called an
esb or an enterprise
service bus before that it was called
eai
before that it was called erp and you
can go back and back and back
the general idea is give me your
spaghetti put it in my
giant spaghetti bowl and uh you'll be
fine
in reality what you end up with is just
a bowl of spaghetti it's it's
proprietary it's impossible to maintain
it's a single point of failure and it
doesn't scale
so what do you do well
instead of concentrating all your
traffic into this single master hub that
doesn't scale and is a single point of
failure
you distribute the stuff that that magic
black box used to do
into each individual micro service
now for those of you in the audience who
are very familiar with microservices i
apologize this is going to sound a
little patronizing
not my intention bear with me i'll get
through it quickly certainly the folks
that i deal with sometimes do
conflate apis and micro services which
are
not the same thing apis are the contract
apis simply define what data comes in
and what data
goes out they are independent of any
implementation
microservices are the implementation so
they're what you do when you take an api
you decide how to make it work
one of the architectural styles you can
use is microservices which effectively
means and i'm oversimplifying a little
bit
that you're going to give each api its
own container its own little stack
running independently independently
upgradeable
independently scalable and independently
deployable
now why would you want to do this
i love jason's talk because he talked
about the intentionality of adopting
microservices i wholeheartedly agree
make sure you're doing it for a reason
and make sure if you're strangling out a
monolith and you're moving to
microservices that you're turning
something off
in the monolith so definitely
use them with intentionality but they're
a very powerful tool and the best way to
explain this
especially if you're working with legacy
is is by way of example
let's say you've got a mainframe some 40
year old piece of iron
and that mainframe does 10 functions and
you decide
i'm going open banking super modern apis
technically speaking you could slap a
gateway in front of that or even some
sort of adapter
that's going to expose the 10 functions
that that mainframe executes
as ultra modern super developer friendly
json rest apis
graphql grpc whatever you want it
doesn't really matter because
the apis are just the contract so you
could write these beautiful apis that
everybody
loves but your implementation underneath
is still mainframe
you put these out into a marketplace
developers start to come to you they
start to
ask for things they say hey function
number ten
can i add a field to that i'd like to
submit a change request to add a field
or a pr i guess or they say
hey that ninth function i i'm gonna need
to hit that 100 times more
than i thought i was going to because of
black friday or something
well guess what if you're still sitting
on your mainframe
you're stuck they are going to have to
wait six months
a year maybe never to get those changes
done
because you can't touch that code it's
sitting in a monolithic
mainframe now by contrast if you take
those 10 apis
and you implement them as 10 separate
microservices which to jason's point you
wouldn't necessarily have to do but bear
with me
you deploy them as 10 different
microservices suddenly if that 10th one
needs to be changed you can change it
without affecting the other nine if the
ninth one needs to scale you can scale
it without affecting the other nine
that's the power of microservices you
essentially get to break down your
problem
and if you did your job uh in the words
of uh
martin fowler you'd never have to
replace your system again
you just have to upgrade pieces
right so that this idea of i never have
a monolith that i have to replace
wholesale is a very attractive idea
in particular in in large enterprise
environments
so we covered why microservices are
better than traditional fat gateways
but even the microservices landscape is
evolving right we heard about serverless
in the in the previous presentation here
it comes again
um so we started with these these fat
gateways these fat monolithic gateways
that were really focused on
uh api management and acting as that
traffic cop and simplifying your life
cycle and all that stuff
if anybody takes issue with where i put
the names stuff moves real fast in this
business so so don't don't take it uh
too much to heart
um the monolithic applications you see
on the left there were basically one
large
application often running in a j2e
environment or something like that
that led to microservices because of all
the benefits i mentioned previously
but uh it was largely based on libraries
so the first shot at trying to
standardize the kind of cross-cutting
concerns that you get out of the gateway
um inside the distributed model where
i'm putting all that stuff
inside each individual microservice was
library based so you saw things like
histrix and finagle
drop wizard was quite popular in the
java community but the idea was i'm
going to compile a module or a library
into my microservice
that takes care of a bunch of stuff for
me security circuit breaker logging etc
and this worked pretty well certainly it
was better than these big traffic cops
and that's why the mature tech companies
would never touch that that leftmost
model with a 10-foot pole
they went to the library model and often
developed their own libraries
but that started to lead to problems
because that doesn't scale either i
don't want to have to recompile all my
microservices every time i make a change
to the library
i don't want to have to manage library
versions i don't want to rely on the
discipline of my delivery teams to make
sure that they're up to date
all of that is just a pain and once you
get to a certain level of scale like in
a diagram
you saw in the previous presentation it
just becomes unmanageable
enter service mesh so service mesh
largely came out
of solving that problem of library-based
distributed gateways
where some smart folks from google
picked up uh some material
the envoy uh code base and some other
stuff from the folks at lyft
and they came up with something called
istio now it's it's worth mentioning
that there were a number of other
service mesh product uh
options available at the time there's
open contrail there's linker d kong the
the cto of kong is a big advocate of
service mesh
so i'm going to get into the details
around service mesh
on the next slide but the idea here was
i'm going to leverage the fact that
these are micro services to effectively
pull the gateway out of each individual
microservice and instead
give each microservice a tiny little
sidecar a little proxy
that sits alongside it and acts as a
traffic cop
just for that microservice
so this seemed to sort of be the best of
both worlds i have this centralized
policy enforcement through these proxies
uh but it's fully distributed fully
microservice based architecture without
any sort of traffic cops
like i said i'm going to get into more
details on that later
it's worth mentioning serverless isn't
the end of the story
there's excuse me service mesh isn't the
end of the story there's server lists
uh that's on the horizon along with a
few other uh technologies like no code
and i've heard kelsey hightower
talk about that himself he thinks it's
pretty funny how far it's gone
but for all the reasons that jason
mentioned i don't think serverless is
ready for prime time in the enterprise
there's a lot of risk of lock-in a lot
of the approaches are are still being
determined it's very volatile
so i would sort of leave it alone for
now
for enterprise scale applications but
certainly worth exploring for
prototyping and to keep an eye on the
future
so where do we go
from here if we're not doing serverless
and uh and and micro service libraries
are unmanageable well
that brings us to the service mesh now i
call this presentation
building the optimal architecture for
open banking i use that word quite
intentionally optimal
when i first wrote this deck i i thought
of calling it the right architecture for
open banking but i didn't like that word
because
it's a moving target things are changing
all the time
so the best thing i can tell you is
what's optimal given the state of the
industry today that might change
tomorrow
but today the service mesh is the
perfect option for open banking
okay why well i get my micro service
isolation so i get my independent
development teams i get my polyglot i
get my
my isolated scaling my isolated uh
upgradability and deployment all the
benefits of microservices
but i don't have to embed a library into
each of the microservices because i have
this handy
sidecar that's running along each one of
them now these side cars they're
automatically injected and deployed when
you deploy your micro services to
kubernetes so there's no work
on behalf of the developers this is if
you're using istio
there's an auto injection mechanism you
basically turn it on inside kubernetes
and every micro service that's deployed
automatically gets a sidecar
deployed alongside it all of these
sidecars
are managed using a control plane if you
want to get nitpicky the sidecars are
technically called the data plane
and in istio they're made up of envoy
sidecars istio strictly speaking is just
the control plane
this is exactly what it sounds like a
centralized interface for managing
exactly what's going on on the proxies
and deploying policy changes to them
asynchronously so you're not messing
with
the the traffic you're not you're not
adding any sort of load
um it's worth noting the perimeter api
gateway acts as an ingress egress point
between a trusted network and an
untrusted network that still stays
but the intention is that it's very
lightweight it's usually a combination
of something like f5
and nginx or or something equally
lightweight like h a proxy it's not
intended to be a thick layer
it's essentially an ssl termination
point
finally all of your collections of
microservices are divided
into domains you may be using a
methodology like domain driven design to
decide how they're grouped together
but that grouping is going to drive some
governance decisions and and how you're
going to structure your teams around the
collections of services
i highly recommend domain driven design
we found it to be a very useful tool for
for dealing with the the growing scale
as you adopt microservices
the term that you should keep in mind
when you're thinking about service mesh
is the distinction
between north-south traffic which is the
stuff that goes up through the perimeter
gateway
and east-west when folks talk about
why service mesh they say because you
should not be treating east-west traffic
the same way you treat
north-south traffic if it's your
internal applications talking to each
other then do not have them run through
some sort of traffic cop sitting on the
edge of your network and then back down
again
you're going to have a bad time it's not
going to scale it's going to lead to all
sorts of problems
so enter the service mesh which
effectively gives you
all of that control but does it in a
completely microservices native
completely friendly way so you get the
best of both worlds you get the
precise control an easy way to tie it
into your api management there are a
number of api
management tools which work nicely with
service mesh tooling
and you get your fully distributed cloud
native microservices architecture
so where is this taking you if you've
got this perfect or excuse me
option optimal architecture for open
banking
well we're headed to the bank of the
future
so in order to actually execute on this
strategy i don't want you to think you
do service
and you've got a silver bullet and all
your problems are solved
success in this space in building the
bank of the future is a balancing act
okay it's a technological and cultural
balancing act on the technology side
remember i said that api regulation open
banking regulation typically only
addresses the api strategy and platform
it doesn't really deal with api's agile
devops and cloud
the thing about these four pillars is
you have to do them all at once
you have to recognize that they're
interdependent because if you slack on
any of them it's going to drag back the
other three
so very quickly if you do all of them
except for apis well you're going to
have this wonderful environment where
you can deploy microservices but you'll
have terrible
apis that nobody wants to use because
you didn't invest anything in api design
or api management
so developers are going to write their
own uh using adam
and they're going to be ugly if you do
all three except agile
well you're really good at delivering
apis and deploying them quickly but you
don't really have any way of capturing
requirements in a meaningful way that a
product owner could manage a backlog and
actually deliver on business
requirements
because they're not talking the same
language if you do everything but devops
is that even worth mentioning you'll
just end up with constraints right so
you'll end up with a bunch of code you
can't deploy
and finally if you do it all without
cloud you're going to hit a wall when
you try to deploy these amazing new
microservices to your legacy
infrastructure
so you have to do all of these in
lockstep and you have to measure your
success as you go across all four
pillars and make sure there's no
laggards
even if you solve all of those problems
you've got the the
organizational structural challenges so
you have to look at conway's law and
figuring out how to reorganize
your organization to fit these kind of
microservices teams
and finally you have to have strong
leadership that is willing to invest in
this change
now what is this change fundamentally
i'm going to talk about it a little from
a technologist's perspective but also
from an open banking perspective
so from a technologist perspective
there's an amazing thing going on
the metaphors for i.t systems
are changing when i was cutting my teeth
the dominant metaphors variety systems
were fixed hard
things architecture meant architecture
like buildings
or city planning or plumbing or building
bridges
and that was comes from the premise that
if you get the design wrong up front the
whole thing is going to collapse
you better nail the design you better do
all the math properly and you don't
start building the bridge
until the blueprint is perfect for a
long time that's how software
was built but that's changing in light
of all of these new
technological advances the metaphors are
changing to things that look a lot more
like biological systems
systems that are built to adapt and
change and evolve
so suddenly when you listen to
microservices talks you'll hear things
about
cells and membranes and chromosomes and
and other
biological things that come from
biological systems thinking
to quote martin fowler you know the
godfather of microservices
he says there is no design at the
beginning you begin by coding a small
amount of functionality
adding more functionality and letting
the design shift and shape
that goes to the heart of what creating
applications using microservices is all
about
creating systems that are built for
change
so how does this relate to open banking
well open banking is all about
innovation and creating systems that are
built to change
why are you doing that you're doing that
to enable the kind of innovation
that open banking demands
now why is open banking demanding
innovation because it's trying to change
the nature
of the relationship that customers have
with their banks
historically let's face it a lot of
customers kind of hate their banks
not my bank all the customers of cibc
love their bank but
other banks some people hate them
why because their whole relationship
with the bank is is
complex and uncertain and frustrating
and
filled with paper and manual processes
and now i have to go to the branch it's
it's it's really not a pleasant
experience and nobody really likes the
bank in the first place
well open banking comes with a sort of
implied promise
it's trying to turn the relationship
into one based on
simplicity transparency
and delight i sort of hate that word
sometimes but for open banking it's true
we are trying to delight our customers
that's the promise
we even got the guy a girlfriend
so so uh
it really is about creating
relationships with customers
that are fundamentally authentic right
ann bowdan
the ceo of starling said it best said
innovation is all about addressing
real issues that customers have and
delivering something they really want
not fees not overdrafts not frustration
but genuine advice
genuine help genuine
warm emotive feelings about their
financial services providers
that's what the challengers are trying
to teach the incumbents is that this is
really about creating authentic customer
relationships
and it is through those authentic
customer relationships that we
the people in this room and similar
rooms like it all over the world
uh are going to create opportunities
that
until today you wouldn't have even been
able to imagine
thank you